Nostalgia Critic: (as Imhotep) You shall rest from life,
like the setting sun in the West.
But you shall dawn anew in the East,
as the first rays of Amon-Ra
dispel the shadows.
[glass break]
Rick: Hyah!
Not today, mummy guy!
Shwing!
Evelyn: *gasp*
Rick: I, being totally from this time period,
am here to stop you!
NC: Cut, cut, cut!
What the hell are you guys doing?
Tamara (British): Well, you told us to dress up as the original Mummy movie.
NC: Yeah!
1932, Boris Karloff!
Tamara and Malcolm: (chuckling)
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Malcolm: Everybody knows that the original Mummy
is the Brendan Fraser version.
Tamara (still British): Why are you dressed up as Grunkle Stan and talking like Frankenberry?
NC: Oh, my God, I'm so sick of people saying this.
The Brendan Fraser one is not the original!
Malcolm: Sure it is.
That's why when the crappy remake came out,
everyone said it's not as good as the original.
Tamara (normal): Yeah, isn't that true?
NC: No!
I mean, yes!
I mean...
It is a sin against nature...
Tamara: And this is that original film.
NC: Nooo.
This was the first crappy remake!
Malcolm: You didn't like it?
NC: I didn't say that.
Malcolm: But you said it was crappy.
NC: Well, it was meant to be crappy.
At least, I pray to God it was.
Tamara: Let's just all come together and agree that the Tom Cruise one
sucks.
NC: Yes.
I mean, no!
I mean...
I want to show people what a great Mummy movie was supposed to be.
Tamara: You thought the Tom Cruise one was great?
NC: THERE'S MORE THAN TWO MOVIES!
Malcolm: Well, people remember the Fraser one.
You should talk about that.
NC: Fine.
I'll leave it to the audience.
How many of you would-
GODDAMN IT!
YOU UNCULTURED SWINES!!
Tamara: Told ya.
NC: Oh, piss off 'til I need an Eragon joke!
NC: Sad to say that, in recent years, when many people refer to the original Mummy movie
this is the one they're talking about.
The 1999 hit quickly established it had as much to do with the original Mummy as, say
The Last Airbender has to do with the original Avatar.
Except a little less penis hair.
Nevertheless, it found its audience, not as a horror film, but rather a corny light-hearted adventure.
It spawned sequels, spin-offs,
even a children's cartoon.
And let me tell you it is no Jackie Chan adventures!
So, after years of popularity
and yes, even future remakes taking more from THIS than the original source material
it does make sense to see if this still holds up or if, honestly, it was ever really meant to hold up.
Let's take a look at 1999's-
Malcolm: The original!
NC: SHUT UP AND WATCH SOMETHING BLACK AND WHITE!
Tamara (British?): NEVEEEEEERRR!!!
NC: ...The Mummy.
It starts off in...
Oh! I'm sorry.
I apparently put out an episode of the cartoon.
OH!
Doubly sorry.
These are apparently "really convincing effects"
Not to knock what is admittedly pretty CG
but Val Kilmer and Ralph Fiennes as Moses and Rameses fit a little too well into this "realistic backdrop."
Narration (Ardeth Bay):
Thebes, crown jewel of Pharaoh Seti I
Home of Imhotep
pharaoh's high priest
Keeper of the Dead.
NC: (as Ardeth) Who enjoys sitting really close to the screen playing Assassin's Creed: Origins.
Oh! Again, I mean, uh...
looking over realistic Egypt.
(normal) I'll give the film credit that has fake as everything looks
it is still a gorgeous and artistically pleasing body of work.
... and the CGI ain't bad either.
Richie:
AM I RIGHT BOYS!?
NC: Imhotep has an affair with the pharaoh's mistress
...which seems redundant the more I think about it.
but the golden Festers are unable to block cock for a long!
(speaks bad Ancient Egyptian)
NC: (as mistress) I had an itch.
What, Egyptians never have an itch?
Or you can kill him! That works.
NC: (normal) But the mistress has a plan for the guards who came to arrest her!
Ha-ha! That showed 'em!
Imhotep plans to resurrect her though, as-
Wait, I can't not play this:
♪[Arabian Nights plays]♪
THIS IS ALL A CARTOON!
Don't believe me?
Look at the effects when trying to bring his love back to life.
Oh my God!
We're in the remake of The Haunting!
DESTROY EVERYTHING EXCEPT
YOUR BI CATHERINE ZETA JONESES!
NC (as mistress): *shudders*
I dreamed I was attached to a giant bomb with Tom Cruise!
(normal) Imhotep has to kill her to resurrect her
but he's stopped and mummified, covered in CG bugs while also given apparently the worst of all curses:
Ardeth: The Medjai would never allow him to be released
for he would arise a walking disease
power over the sands and the glory of invincibility!
NC: Kind of a dumb curse when you think about it.
"Ah yes. You will suffer for years and years
and if by chance somebody saves you
you'll become the most powerful and invincible entity known to man."
Were there no other curses that left that part out?
Wha- was that curse on sale?
Ardeth: And for 3,000 years, we, the Medjai
the descendants of Pharaoh's sacred bodyguards
kept watch.
NC: Ah, geez, these guys have the laziness of the Cruciform sword of written all over them.
If you did your job well, we wouldn't have a movie!
We come across a desert battle and meet our main character Rick, played by Fraser
and his comic relief, Beni.
Beni: Wait for me!
NC: Don't worry.
He'll be back soon to confused charming side antagonist with
"SHUT UP! J-J-JU SHUT UP!!"
soon enough.
Thank God they set their rifles to "around target" instead of "on target"
as Spooky-face-in-the-ground scares everyone away including Fraser.
Banish him to Monkeybone.
Meanwhile, Rachel Weisz plays a librarian named Evelyn
who's searching in the S section for "Suck-ass comedy".
It's funny because...
Nope.
I'll give them a point that they actually knocked all these bookcases over in one shot with no CG involved.
It almost excuses the lame-ass exposition we have to sit through.
Dr. Bey: Why do I put up with you?!
Evelyn: W-Well, you put up with me because I can-I can read and write ancient Egyptian.
And I can-I can decipher hieroglyphics and hieratic.
NC: (as Evelyn) I force plot-points with no natural rhyme or rhythm.
(normal) She thinks she hears a noise, so she grabs one of those necessary
TORCHES KEPT AROUND ANCIENT ARTIFACTS!
I guess electricity wasn't a common thing yet.
OH WAIT!
where she's led to her piss-poor fake-out.
*screaming*
Evelyn: Have you no respect for the dead?
NC: Uh, yeah, messing with priceless corpses in Egypt?
Best-case scenario: fired
Worst-case scenario: death!
This is Jonathan, Weisz's brother
who just happened to find the Hellraiser box which contains a map to Egyptian tombs and treasure.
This looks like a job for pervy George of the Jungle!
Rick: Who are you?
And who's the broad?
Evelyn: You were actually at Hamunaptra?
Rick: Yeah, I was there.
Evelyn: You swear?
Rick: Every damn day.
Evelyn: No, I didn't mean that.
Rick: I know what you meant. I was there.
Seti's place, City of the Dead.
NC: (as Rick) My slightly dirty skin and perfect white teeth are ready for rugged adventure!
(normal) So, yeah, Brendan Fraser sticks out like a member of Scrubs in an Indiana Jones movie
but given the film's goofy tone, you could argue that's the point.
It is a silly environment, so his mismatched voice and look doesn't go unwelcome.
Rick: Then get me the hell out of here!
My problem is there would have been so many other non-matching actors that would have been even cooler!
Can you imagine Bruce Campbell in that role?
It'd make no sense, but it'd be awesome!
Rob (as Campbell): Who are you and who's the broad?
Get me the hell outta here and, by God
tell me why that guy's in that hamster wheel!
IT'S NOT EVEN ATTACHED TO ANYTHING!
NC: Sadly, though, Fraser is said to hang, and...
Short movie.
Actually, his neck doesn't break which
allows Weisz time to bargain for his life
telling his captor that if he releases him, she'll lead them to the treasure.
He agrees not realising forced romantic interludes
are a shitty-ass Lucas wipe away.
Evelyn: He's filthy, rude, a complete scoundrel.
I don't like him one bit.
Rick: Anyone I know?
Evelyn: Oh.
NC: (as Evelyn) Oh!
My horniness totally forgot what I was saying.
Rick: My whole damn garrison believed in this so much
that without orders, they marched halfway across Libya and into Egypt to find that city.
And when we got there, all we found was sand and blood.
NC: (as Rick) Like, it totally put me off my surfing lessons.
I'm a rogue.
Evelyn: One of the most famous books in history is buried out there.
The Book of Amun-Ra.
Rick: And the fact that they say it's made out of pure gold makes no nevermind to you.
Right?
NC: (as Rick) I was thinking of dyeing my hair gold.
Would that be cool?
I'm a lowlife.
Evelyn: Why did you kiss me?
Rick: I don't know. I was about to be hanged.
It seemed like a good idea at the time.
NC: (as Evelyn): I thought we had something,
man I've known for less than a day!
Rick: What?
NC: (normal) They sail on a ship, discovering that another troop happens to be looking
for the exact same thing
on the exact same ship.
They even come across the exact same wormy comic relief.
Beni: You're alive!
I was so very, very worried.
NC: Bartok the Bat?
Beni: They pay me only half now, half when I get them back the Cairo.
Bartok: Am I supposed to believe that thing woke up
after all these years?
Beni: You never believed in Hamunaptra, O'Connell.
Bartok: Oh, sure, blame the bat. What the heck?
We're easy targets.
NC: Admit it, you are not gonna unhear this!
But a Universal stunt show breaks out, and everybody is forced to abandon the ship.
They manage to come across some camels, and, surprisingly, they DON'T focus on their flatulence.
You missed a cinematic diamond mine.
...and they travel to the ruins, using day for night, and dumb for smart.
David Daniels: What the hell are we doin'?
Beni: Patience, my good barat'm.
Patience.
Bartok: You know, sir, really, you should watch your blood pressure.
Stress, it's a killer, sir.
Rick: We're about to be shown the way.
NC: You sure it's not just playing a DuckTales cartoon?
My God, these effects!
David: Can you believe it?
Bernard Burns: Hamunaptra.
Rick: Here we go again.
NC: (as Rick) Derp.
So they make it to the city and start looking for riches.
Film was used to shoot that rope scene.
I think we all acknowledge it was worth it.
They journey inward to see what they can find.
Rick: They ripped out your guts and stuffed them in jars.
Evelyn: And then they'd take out your heart as well.
NC: Well, that's the end of them.
No, they just missed it
...goddammit
...and find the Book of the Dead.
Fraser's captor, however, finds one of the deadly bugs
concealed in a Cadbury egg
that somehow survived all these years
despite being in a Cadbury egg.
Oh, no!
I'm being Photoshopped to death!
NC: Christ, is Macaulay Culkin in that tomb with them?
He died as he lived.
Like Curly Howard.
The Cruciform Morons show up a day late
proving they suck at what they do
and making them even more dumb when they just tell them to leave, and then, they leave.
Ardeth: Leave.
Leave this place or die.
NC: Oh.
Those are our choices, huh?
Hey, you notice how their backs are to us right now?
Of course, having half your crew killed and your life threatened
doesn't mean you can't get smashed the exact same night!
Evelyn: I know when to say no.
Rick: And unlike your brother, miss, you, I just don't get.
Evelyn: I am going to kiss you, Mr. O'Connell.
Rick: Call me Rick.
NC: Kurt Russell.
That would have been a weird but badass choice.
I could totally see him in that role!
Rob: (as Russell) Call me Rick.
And, for God's sakes, grow your eyebrows back.
What are you doing?
NC: (as Rick) Well. I'd say never on a first date
but this never happens on a first date.
(normal) *snickers* Okay.
That's the one thing Brendan Fraser could add that nobody else could add.
This whole entire performance might be worth it just for that one reaction!
You hold on to that, Fraser!
Let no one take that from you.
But they discover Imhotep's corpse and are surprised to find he's still decomposing after all these years.
Perhaps it has something to do with the remains of the bugs in his tomb.
Evelyn: They can stay alive for years, feasting on the flesh of a corpse.
Rick: So somebody threw these in with our guy and then they slowly ate him alive?
Evelyn: Very slowly.
NC: Yes. As we already saw
they really take their time there.
They're like flesh-eating snails.
The other guys find ancient soap dispensers, unaware that they hold some of Imhotep's vital organs.
This'll make him happy, though, when he wakes up after Doof and Doofus
read the passage that resurrects him from the Book of the Dead.
See how much cooler that would be?
This unleashes a plague of fake-ass locusts, sadly not led by James Earl Jones.
All hell starts to break loose as even more of those bugs are released.
Still eating people super-slowly, as you can see.
Evelyn: Very slowly.
NC: You know, has anyone considered she has no idea what she's talking about?
Thus, only an hour in, we finally get our mummy, and...
Pretty sure Legends of the Hidden Temple would've done him better.
Yeah, it's...pretty bad.
I mean, given the time period, it's...
pretty bad.
NC: Okay, now we're trying to do a Trollface
if it was on a...
if it was on a tree from The Wizard of Oz.
What are we doing?!
Fraser saves her by blasting his Imho-dick.
But the crucified schmucks block them off.
Ardeth: I told you to leave or die.
You refused.
Now you may have killed us all.
NC: You know, I love the way this guy says everything.
No matter what he's talking about, I feel like it should always be followed by
"Man!" or "Ya know?"
Ardeth: I told you to leave or die.
NC: Man!
You refused.
NC: Ya know?
Now you may have killed us all.
NC: Man!
Rick: Relax, I got him.
Ardeth: No mortal weapon can kill this creature.
NC: Ya know?
He's not of this world.
NC: Man.
But Imhotep comes across Beni, who quite amusingly prays to every religion he can think of.
Bartok: Actually, considering how long you've been dead, you look pretty good.
NC: Were you just keeping those in your pelvic bone?
You have no skin
you have no clothes.
There's nowhere else you could keep it.
This really needs an answer despite how much I don't want it!
So Fraser suggests they leave
Weisz suggests they stay
and the rest of us debate if this sounds more like Will and Grace or Mad About You.
Rick: I told you not to play around with that thing.
Didn't I tell you not to play around with that thing?
Evie: Yes, right then.
Me, me, me, me, I, I, I woke him up, and I intend to stop him.
Rick: Oh, yeah? How?
You heard the man.
No mortal weapons can kill this guy.
NC: Christ. At this point,
I'd take Archer in this role.
(as Archer) Look, you can either tag along with me or stay here and try to save the world.
Do you want mummies?
'Cause this is how you get mummies.
LANA!!!
(normal) Fraser goes to the bar to get hammered, where an ex-pilot talks about his woes about there being no adventures anymore.
I'm sure absolutely nothing in the near future will tie into this.
Havlock: Chucked it in with the others and gone down in flame and glory
instead of sitting around here
rotting of boredom and booze.
Rick: rotting from boredom and booze.
NC: Yes, Chairman Mouse from The Rescuer movies.
Oh. It...
actually is him.
Random.
NC: The mummy and Beni locate one of the people who took the sacred jars.
Benny: I'm afraid more is needed
Burns: (whimpering) Wha?...
Beni: The prince must finish the job and consummate the curse...
Bartok: I guess a curse just ain't what it used to be, huh, sir?
Beni: ...which you and your friends have brought down upon yourselves.
Burns: Wait! No!
NC: (as Burns) *screams*
On a side note, that was very nice of you to fill me in before you kill me.
I mean, I know you got a lot on your plate right now
and time is probably of the essence
so it was very considerate of you to do
*resumes screaming*
Rick: We are in serious trouble.
NC: You know, I should probably count how many times a good one-liner is instead replaced by Brendan Fraser making a stupid face and stating the obvious.
That happens a lot around here.
I'll be seeing you again.
These guys just don't quit, do they?
This just keeps gettin' better and better.
We are in very serious trouble.
NC: The mummy moves in on Weisz, but gets pussy whipped being afraid of cats, who are revealed to be the guardians of the Underworld.
Weisz's boss was in cahoots with the Cruciform Dorks and helped him in their terrible job of protecting the world.
Dr. Bey: Apparently, even after 3,000 years...
Ardeth: He's still in love with her.
NC: Man!
Ardeth: Perhaps he will once again try to raise her from the dead.
NC: Ya know?
Jonathan: And he stretched forth his hand towards the heavens
and there was darkness throughout...
NC: Oh, yeah, because that brother character is entirely useless
they try to justify him by having him quote the Bible every time something plaguey happens.
Jonathan: ...and there was darkness throughout the land of Egypt.
And the rivers and waters of Egypt ran red and were as blood.
NC: Oh, shut up, VeggieTales, you're still pointless!
So Fraser decides to lock Weisz in her room
leave the other rogues to look after her
and bring the brother with him to find Imhotep.
Rick: She doesn't come out, and no one goes in, right?
Henderson: Right.
Rick: Let's go, Jonathan.
NC: Wow!
Every single one of those choices was wrong!
She knows the most about the mummy, so she should go along.
They're more qualified to fight, so they should go along.
And he, I refer you back to useless.
Does anyone know how to do their job in this movie?
I guess he didn't want a repeat of what happened:
him running into Beni
the mummy killing another scrounger
putting the moves on Weisz
a plague happening and being scared by a cat.
So, what happens?
He runs into Beni, the mummy kills another scrounger, puts the moves on Weisz, a plague happens, and he's scared by a cat.
Mr. Salt: We've just come through there!
NC: Yeah, with the exception of the explanation with Weisz's boss, which, even then, I feel we could have figured out
the past eight minutes are just a repeat and totally should've been deleted.
But, at least two more souls are sucked dry, which means the mummy must look at least a little more realistic now.
...as realistic as a cartoon mouth app on your phone.
Is this mummy meant to be scary or adorable?
I'm gonna say "ascarable".
Imhotep hypnotizes an army and forces them to go after our heroes.
Jonathan: Faster.
Evie: Patience is a virtue.
Rick: Not right now, it isn't.
They escape through the back, but the mummy has a extra trick up his sleeve.
Okay.
Glad you got that out of your system.
The army eventually corners them, as the fully regenerated Imhotep approaches.
And is Weisz is anything like she was earlier, she's probably like...
NC: (as Evelyn) Ooh!
That's what he looks like when put together?
Imhotep: Keetah mi pharos...
NC: (as Evelyn) Whatever he's asking, yes.
Imhotep: ...isirian.
Beni: (translating) "Come with me, my princess."
"Take my hand, and I will spare your friends."
Bartok: Is this the face of a bat who would lie to you?
NC: She decides to go with him, under the condition that he spares her friends.
He agrees...
He agrees to disagree.
Evie: No!
Let go of me!
NC: It was the noble...
stupid thing to do.
Her boss sacrifices himself so the rest can escape
and they go to Chairman Mouse for the use of his plane.
Havlock: What's the challenge, then?
Rick: Rescue the damsel in distress
kill the bad guy
save the world.
NC: (as Havlock) Oh, one of these bullshit movies.
Right-o!
(normal) Imhotep travels via Warp Whistle, and I gotta say
for being in the sandstorm
they look pretty damn good.
But Mr. Sandman isn't done yet.
NC: My God!
This must be Anakin Skywalker's worst nightmare!
Anakin: I don't like sand.
NC: Look out!
Sand F. Murray Abraham!
He swallows the plane up
though, I guess, not too deep, seeing how there's plenty of blue sky insight
but Weisz has an idea.
NC: (as Rick) Oh, God, now the storm's tongue is attacking us!
What's going on?!
(normal) But it appears to not be enough.
Beni: I like the whole sand wall trick. It was beautiful...
...bastard.
NC: (as Rick Sanchez) You don't need to impress me, Morty.
(normal) Sadly, the only character I sympathize with
the drunk who just wants to die, gets killed.
But if we're lucky, maybe we can go for two.
NC: YES!
"Very slowly" eat him alive!
Evelyn: Very slowly.
NC: Sadly, he's saved, but Imhotep hears them and sends his biggest threat yet...
mummies that are actually there!
Oh, my God!
They're actually right in front of us!
I mean, really right there!
It's not Jar Jar shit!
RUN!!
Oh, whoops. Don't worry, we still got the fake shit over here.
Yeah, surprisingly, playing the exact same effect doesn't make it look any more real.
It still looks like a Smurf sneezed milk through his nose.
The mummy of Imhotep's bride comes to life, though, but before he can make the human sacrifice
Fraser saves the day.
Imhotep: Im yub set na.
NC: They forgot to subtitle that scene, so
I'll just throw my own in.
And for creature as powerful as a god, Imhotep doesn't really do that much, outside of just watching them fight and go
"Thank God I'm not the butt-ugly CGI Rock in the shitty-ass sequel."
And when he does finally fight, he just utilizes more Mario Paint effects.
*snickers* You know, call me crazy, but
dropping your jaw like the Patrick the starfish meme doesn't seem particularly scary.
Look at that!
Did the Genie lend you some acting advice or something?
This was meant to be a Disney film, right?
But Weisz reads one last passage that takes away his invincibility, making him mortal.
Of course, everything starts falling apart, and Beni is left behind in the treasure room.
(as a scarab) Hello.
We'll be your comeuppance for the evening.
Bartok: This can only end in tears!
NC: (as Beni) At least you'll very slowly eat me.
(as a scarab) What dumbass told you that?
Evelyn: Very slowly.
NC: Run, camels, run!
I care more about you than any of the main characters!
(as Rick) I'm only kissing you 'cause I think I'm gonna get hanged later.
Jonathan: How 'bout you, darling?
Would you like a little kissy-wissy?
NC: Well, it's no camel fart
but his entire character is close enough.
So that was the remake, not the original, of The Mummy.
Does it hold up?
No, but I don’t think that was really the point.
It’s kind of like a high-budget B-movie
self-aware, silly and over-the-top.
Some would say the bigger budget makes it less of a B-movie, but look at these effects.
They look like the effects of today’s B-movies.
So I feel like it still kind of qualifies.
On top of that, it is still visually pleasant and fairly imaginative that I think, for a silly little waste of time, it’s fine.
It’s in no way comparable to the original, but I think even the makers of the film knew that it wasn’t going to be.
The best way I can put it is
“enjoyably dated”.
NC: Right, now we're going to talk about The Mummy film that's worth talking about!
Nerd: You said it, Critic.
NC: NEEEERRRRRR-
Wait, what are you doing here?
Nerd: I want to help you talk about The Mummy movie that's worth talking about.
NC: Oh, of course.
With your love of monster movies, it only makes sense that you want to talk about...
Nerd: ...the 2017 Tom Cruise version.
NC: WHAT, ARE YA OUT OUT OF YOUR MIND?!
Nerd: No.
But the movie is!
It's one of the most dumbass reboots ever, and we need to talk about it.
NC: Yeah, but...what about the original Mummy?
Nerd: You mean the 1932 classic with Boris Karloff and the Kharis series starring Lon Chaney Jr.
or the 1959 Hammer version with Christopher Lee?
You mean...
THE GOOD ONES?!
I already talked about them on Cinemassacre.
Here's the link.
NC: Wha- *stammers*
Don't advertise your channel on my channel!
Nerd: Look, everything about the classic versions has been already said.
They're masterpieces.
But this new one, we need to give it what it deserves.
NC: *sigh* Oh, my god...
So we're really ending Nostalgia-Ween like this?
Will it still even be October by the time this comes out?
Nerd: It doesn't matter.
To defend the honor of the classic Mummies, we have to do this.
NC: *sigh* Fine. All right.
Next week, we'll review one of this year's biggest nostalgic cash-grabs resulting in one of this year's biggest bombs.
Nerd: Oh, Amun-Ra, God of Gods.
Death is but the doorway to new life.
We live today, we shall live again.
In many new forms shall-
NC: Oh, shut up.
Beni: (praying in Hindi)
Hey. Doug Walker here doing the charity shout out once again.
And if you've been watching the news you're probably aware of the fires going on in, California.
But rather than me talk about it one of our producers who lives out in California
Bennett The Sage, is going to tell you all about it and what you can do to help.
Bennett: On October 8th 2017, the city of Santa Rosa experienced unprecedented destruction.
A wildfire, which has hence been titled the Tubbs Fire, had rapidly formed fueled by large amounts of dry vegetation due to years of drought
and Gusts of wind that reached hurricane level speeds the havoc it rot left over 5,000 buildings destroyed five percent of the total housing area of Santa Rosa with over a billion dollars in total damages.
This, combined with the staggering casualty total of 22 lives lost, makes the Tubbs fire the most destructive in California history.
As of October 19th the Tubbs fire has been 90% contained
but the after-effects of this disaster will be felt for years to come.
but in times of devastation
the human capacity for kindness and generosity will always shine through.
And I'm here to ask for that same light to help my city recover.
Right now, a donation page has been set up by the chief financial officer of Santa Rosa to help those that have been affected by the Tubbs fire
and I urge everyone who sees this video to donate what they can to help those that have lost everything to a chance
and cruel moment of chaos.
Click on the link in the description to donate or go to you caring comm and search for Tubbs fire victims
Please also share this video on social media to help this Culver aid with your help, Santa Rosa can rise again
Thank you